be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Batman rebirth and what
I'm hoping is that at the end of all
this you'll have a good idea of where
the series stands and how it expects to
shape up going into the future of DC
Comics so much like Green Arrow and the
rest of the rebirth releases Batman
draws on a combination of pulling the
past and the present together however
the difficulty of this concept comes in
the idea that DC has never been
straightforward about Bruce's past
events in relation to the new 52 what I
mean here is that where the rest of DC's
lineup largely received clean-cut
reboots Batman's past continuity was
left ambiguous with occasional
references here and there including
Batman eternal which saw the return of
Thomas Eliot who referenced a pre
flashpoint story hush while Barbara
Gordon discussed her recovery after
being shot during the pre flashpoint
story Killing Joke to this end while
this did offer the potential to maintain
the canonicity of some of Batman's most
iconic stories including nightfall on
the whole the reader was left in a
quagmire being expected to believe that
everything from crisis on Infinite
Earths to flashpoint all happened in a
five-year window while not actually
being told whether it did now where much
of the confusion fell to the wayside in
the face of scott Snyder's run with the
introduction of the court of owls and
the return of the Joker during death of
the family and ingame as part of
Snyder's multi-part epic the fact
remains that even if fans weren't
beating down the doors of DC for answers
at the very least some measure of
cohesiveness was expected to be
forthcoming they for no other reason
than to add depth to Bruce Wayne's life
experiences while fans look to the idea
of rebirth as a way for DC to provide
the answers they were looking for
instead the readers walked away
empty-handed being left with a multitude
of unanswered questions and a bit of
confusion written by Tom King and Scott
Snyder one of the biggest drawbacks of
the issue is that we don't actually know
whose hand is in the cookie jar while
the book feels almost exactly like
something Snyder would write Tom Keens
name is still listed as co-writer
leaving us to ask whether or not the
book is an actual representation of what
to expect going forward into the series
but initially opening up with Alfred in
the midst of tending the garden Wayne
Manor is
by the arrival of Duke Thomas in
response to a previously extended offer
to sidetrack for a second Duke Thomas
was one of several heroes introduced as
part of the we are Robin line of comics
under the banner of DCU written by
Lieber Mayo and drawn by Rob Haines and
Kari Randolph while it only spanned 12
issues the story focused on Duke Thomas
along with a handful of other teenagers
all of whom adopted the mantle of Robin
and operated as vigilantes after being
inspired by various members of the bat
family receiving fairly high reviews but
experiencing mediocre sales like many of
DC's titles we are Robin was cancelled
between the announcement of DC Lee birth
and the lead-up to its launch at the
beginning of June however focusing on
the story the events contained within
center are kind of truer Bruce Wayne's
life as it progresses throughout the
length of a week meeting with Lucius Fox
on a Tuesday the conversation between
the two is not of stupendous importance
instead it follows a standard method of
Snyder storytelling providing a bit of
mortar between the bricks of Batman's
events giving us some insight into his
own personal life to this end with
Lucius Fox recounting a conversation
that Bruce's father on why Thomas Wayne
became a doctor where Lucius founded a
bit foolhardy and the definition of
insanity by helping the sick while
knowing they would only get sick again
the rhetorical question is designed to
highlight the necessity of Bruce Wayne
being Batman and that while the
criminals he catches always escaped
creating an endless cat-and-mouse game
the cycle exists because it needs to if
for no other reason than to keep
criminals from achieving their goal and
Gotham falling into disarray following
this the story transitions to Wednesday
with Bruce Wayne revealing to Duke that
Gotham has been met with the return of
calendar man a being whose life changes
with the seasons meaning he dies in the
winter is reborn in the spring and ages
through the summer and fall with the
cycle repeating itself now where this is
really just background stuff it's not
her and King giving us something to read
while we make our way through the comic
the overall theme here is that Duke
continues to stay along for the ride
bring him to the Batcave the purpose
behind Dukes presence is revealed with
Batman providing a home form in the wake
of his parents insanity to sidetrack
here during the events of Batman in game
and Joker's attack on Gotham with the
juror intending to reenact the death of
Bruce Wayne's parents by using the
parents of Duke the toxic media's had
permeated their minds pushing them into
insanity without an immediate cure
we're verse was able to rescue Duke and
escape Dukes parents were left behind
leaving Duke himself as an orphan using
this as a jumping-off platform while
neither King nor Snider offer direct
answer the implication seems to be that
Duke is being offered a position
alongside Batman that is akin to the
Robin mantle but remains ambiguous with
Duke appearing receptive to the idea
this revelation is really the only
standout part of the story in truth
things essentially fall back into rank
and file with Batman coming to the
realization the calendar man had planted
spores around Gotham which if released
will kill everyone in the city now as
far as I'm aware there's no real
explanation available about these spores
and it seems to be designed that way
what I mean here is that because this
rebirth issue appears to be written in
the form of a week in the life of Bruce
Wayne it plays on the notion of every
comic being an end of Gotham scenario
and the idea that Batman is the only one
who can save the day well the story does
see Batman succeeding and destroying
Calendar man's machines as well as
depicting his rebirth in the form of
shedding his old body and emerging as a
younger person the events shift their
focus to a conversation between Batman
and Duke with Bruce revealing that where
Duke is concerned about calendar man
returning and constantly thinking up new
ideas their roles as heroes is to meet
the challenge and comeback themselves
equally more intelligent and capable and
so with the story wrapping itself up
this seems to reveal the shortcoming of
the issue nothing really happens the
comic makes no reference to Snyder's
Batman aside from Dukes parents during
the events of endgame it makes no
reference to the supposed death of Bruce
Wayne after in-game and Commissioner
Gordon taking on the mantle of Batman
and as far as I can tell the entire
issue treats the events of DC U as if
they never happened picking up almost
immediately after the Joker's perceived
death I think
using an in-game with Bruce Wayne taking
Duke on as award with that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end
and let me know what you guys thought
about Batman rebirth if you read it
maybe I'm just preceding it the wrong
way but with that being said I won't
catch you guys on her piece